sie bekommen heute anderen
videoinstallation unsere location ich
setze mich so häufig antreffe
verteidigung noch nie weil ich das
einfach daran dass wir heute nicht an
einer aufgabe sondern
[Musik]
klar wollen wir verteilen keine dagegen
wahrscheinlich innerlich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer heute behauptet die beiden in der
vorwärtsbewegung ist das weil er im
rahmen der in drei akten
wir sind noch nicht an der entscheidung
etwas ähnliches gefährt gerade noch mal
weniger glück hatte die banken aufgelegt
werden wird bemerkt dass mit dem zug ein
richtiger luca wieder ehrlich gesagt so
[Musik]
gut wie keine
letztlich brachte abschluss mache ich
denn vereinen
reiter hat irgendwie zweiten schritt
würde oder gehalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tennis
[Musik]
[Applaus]
lukas gerade die wahrhaftige mister von
super talent vaude musste deswegen ja
jetzt gerade in komischen ekelhafte vor
trinken wer jedoch auf weitere videos
habt werdet ihr hier ein eingeblendeter
kadera drauf irgendwo findet jetzt ihr
video angehören könnten abonnieren